so I want to get to SpaceTime is not
doomed there's quite a few subjects I
still have to get to I want to be
mindful of your time but how about we
talk about SpaceTime not being doomed
it's something that's said now I don't
know if you know but there's someone
named Donald Hoffman who frequently
cites this he's not a physicist but he
cites it as evidence or support for his
Consciousness as fundamental View and
then there's Nima arani Hamed who's the
popularizer of that term though not the
inventor yeah so maybe to to I mean I
can kind of summarize that yeah so I I
don't really have anything useful say
about about Hoffman I me so he's
interested in Consciousness and other
things I don't really I don't really
know much about or useful to say but
maybe to say what the um and mean the
reason I wrote that there's this article
you're referring to about SpaceTime is
not Doom I I I wrote partly because I
was getting frustrated at how this had
become such a an ideology among people
among people and um working in physics
and on quantum gravity this this idea
that when people first started thinking
about how do you get quantized gravity
how do you Quant gravity so the the
initial one of the initial ideas was
well we've learned that we have this
incredible successful successful
standard model so let's just use the
same methods that work for the standard
model and apply them to gravity and
we'll do that so it's going to be and
you're thinking of space and time in
this usual way and then there are these
degrees of freedom live in space in time
which which tell you about the the
metric and and the geometry of space and
time and you're trying to write a
quantum theory of those things living in
space and time people tried to do this
there there's lots of problems with
doing it it's it's an incredibly long
story string theory was partly reaction
to the story but even string theory was
still a theory of strings moving around
in space and time so you weren't
starting thinking thinking in terms of a
space and time but but more recently you
know as String Theory hasn't really
worked out the way people expected there
has been this ideology of oh well let's
just get rid of this space and time
somehow and we will write some theory in
in some completely different kind and in
the low energy limit will recover space
and time as some kind of effective
structure which you only see at low
energies and that's become almost an
ideology like Aran Hamed likes to say
SpaceTime is doomed you know meaning the
the truly fun theory is going to be in
some other VAR variables and space-time
variables he has his own proposals for
this about these geometrical structures
he's using to study amplitudes anyway
the things that I'm that I'm doing you
actually do get a theory it looks like
you know gravity should fit into this
and it will fit into this in a fairly
standard way um this is standard space
and time except you know that in the
Twister geometry point of view on it
and interesting things happening with
the Spinners you didn't expect but it's
still there is a usual ideas about space
and time are are are there so problem
with with with this whole kind of space
time is Doom thing is you have to have a
plausible proposal for what you're going
to replace it with it's all well and
good to say that there's some completely
different Theory out there and the
theory people used to is just an
effective approximation first you got to
convince me that your alternative
proposal is it works and and and the
problem is that people are just doing
this without any kind of plausible or
interesting proposal for what it is
you're going to replace space time with
and often and often it even comes down
to this crazy level of kind of this
Multiverse thing I you know we have this
Theory where everything happens so
fundamentally everything happens but
then effectively you only see space and
time and it's kind of you know can say
words like that but it's it's kind of
meaningless MH why is it that they have
to come up with a decent proposal or
replacement why can't they just say look
there are some with our current two
theories there's an incompatibility that
suggests that SpaceTime quote unquote
breaks down at the plank level or maybe
before so for instance neema's argument
that if you were to measure anything
with it classically you have to put an
infinite amount of information somewhere
and then that creates a black hole and
then there's also something with the
black hole entropy y that
suggests holography but that doesn't
mean SpaceTime is doomed it's just a
different SpaceTime yeah yeah yeah no
but from my point of VI I mean what what
what has been come the focus of that
field a lot is this is is are actually
quite tricky you know very
non-perturbative very kind of strong
field problems about how you know what's
going to happen to the theory when
you've got black holes and black holes
are decaying and so you've kind of moved
away from but but but the problem with
the inconsistency between normally that
is normally the one everybody worries
about is is is normally different
problem it's a very very local problem
it's just that if you um if you think of
this in terms of the standard standard
kind of variables like like what's
the the metric variables and you use the
Einstein Hilbert action for the Dynamics
for these things if you try and apply
standard ideas of quantum field Theory
locally to that at Short distances is
you get these renormalization problems
and the theory becomes unpredictive so
that's always been considered the real
problem how do you deal how do you deal
with that but instead of having a
proposal to deal with that and having a
a real a new idea about what what's
really going to happen you know what are
the right variables at these short
distances that will not have this
problem what what what are you going to
do they kind of ignore that decided to
ignore that problem and say well maybe
String Theory solves that problem who
knows and and and then to move on and to
try to do you know something much much
harder which is to to resolve these
issues about what happens in black hole
backgrounds and stuff and uh I know but
but it seems to me kind of a separ a
separate issue you can still have
SpaceTime and have these these these
issues about you know what's going to
happen in in black hole backgrounds and
stuff and you could still resolve them
in different ways but but they're just
really it's it's a very frustrating
subject I think find to actually to try
to learn about you see people making
these statements and then you say okay
well what what exactly do they mean I
mean it's all well and good to say these
very vague things about this is doomed
and what what about infinite amount of
information blah blah blah but you know
write down tell me what we're talking
about here and there there really isn't
uh it's it's almost like comically
impossible to kind of pin people down on
what is the what are you talking what
theory are you talking about
and it and then finally when you pin
them down you find out that what they're
actually talking about is
they've they're talking about some very
very toy model they're saying well we
don't know what's going on in four
dimensions so let's try it in three
dimensions and maybe two Dimensions
maybe one dimension and so they're
talking about some comically trivial um
toy model which they kind of ended up
studying because where you could study
it and that maybe there's some analogous
problem happening there and and that all
they have are these kind
of toy models which which actually don't
seem to have any of the actual real
physics of four-dimensional gen
relativity in them and that's what
they're that's what they're all studying
these days I see even
Nema well I mean he he's somewhat
different because he's coming at it from
a different point of view he's coming at
it from this point of view of of really
trying to
see find new structures in the um in the
perturbative expansions for um you know
for standard Quantum fi theories so he's
got a he's got kind of a specific
program looking at
um yeah I mean he's he's not he in
generaliz he's not studying toy models
he's studying real four-dimensional
right physical models but but they're
not
um but but but they're they're they're
often they're generally models like Yang
military you know exactly where the
theory is and it's not this is this
isn't solving the problem quantum
gravity or anything it's it's a
it's well in theory but I I I think
maybe I should I'm saying this a bit too
quickly without thinking but but but
just to try to give a a flavor what I
think he thinks he's doing he's he's
he's trying to take a theory that you do
understand well like Yang Mills Theory
and look at look at its perturbation
series findan diagrams find new
structures there and a new language and
then see if you can build rebuild the
theory in terms of the new structures
and and and and then then if you've got
kind of a new way of thinking about
Quantum field theory in terms of these
new different structures like his
amplitude hedrin or whatever then maybe
you can then
apply once you've got a way of thinking
terms of those new structures you can go
back to the problem of quantum gravity
and and andol that yeah so I think but
you know I don't think he he's not in
anyway as far as I know claiming to have
actually gotten anywhere near there but
he's and and this this gives you a lot
to do there's a lot of interesting
structure there there's a lot to work on
and and so he and his collaborators have
you know have done a huge amount kind of
calculation with these things but I at
least to my mind I I don't see them kind
of coming up with what I think they they
hope to come up with which is a a
different geometric language for for
that that really works and is really
powerful for um that that's going to get
you something new if you enjoyed that
clip then the full podcast is out right
now you can click around here enjoy
subscribe to theories of everything to
get notified of upcoming podcasts as
there are new full length podcasts every
week on the topics of mathematics
physics Consciousness Free Will and
AI